>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
[silence]
>> JOAN WEEKS: Good afternoon
Ladies and Gentlemen.
On behalf of my colleagues and
in particular Dr. Mary-Jane Deeb,
Chief of the African and
Middle East Division,
I would like to extend a very
warm welcome to everyone.
I'm Joan Weeks, Head of
the Near East section
and that is the sponsor
of today's program.
We're very pleased to present
this program on the discovery
of the secret of the great pyramid
and the tomb of Tutankhamun.
And before we start today's program,
we just like to give you a brief
overview, especially our newcomers
to our division in the hopes that
you'll come back and do research
with us or attend further programs.
This is a custodial division and
it's got three sections that build
and serve collections for
researchers around the world.
We cover over 78 countries
and two dozen languages.
The Africa section covers all of the
countries of South Saharan Africa.
The Hebraic section is
responsible for Hebraica worldwide
and the Near East section
covers all of the Arab countries
of North Africa, all of the
Middle East of course, Turkey,
Turkic Central Asia, Iran,
Afghanistan, and the Muslims
in Western China, the Balkans,
and the peoples of the Caucuses.
So, it's a very wide region
of collection and expertise
in this reading room to
serve these collections.
Now, just a few things we like
to always invite you to fill
in the evaluation form that
we've left in your seats
that helps us design future programs
and we also have put this little
flyer about blog and Facebook.
And if you subscribe to our
Facebook, you get announcements
of future programs and the blog has
some very very interesting articles
written by our curators.
So, we really invite you to do that.
And we also say today that this
program is being videotaped,
webcast.
So, if you want to ask
questions at the end,
you are implicitly
giving your permission
to be videotaped and recorded.
Just to make sure you
understand that.
And also we have a very special
booklet up here that- all
about the Library of Congress
and we laid out copies here
so you're welcome to take
those before you leave.
And for right now, I'll introduce
my dear colleague, Dr. Fawzi Tadros,
our Arab world specialist to
introduce our speaker today.
[pause]
>>FAWZI TADROS: Ladies and
Gentlemen, today I have the pleasure
of introducing a distinguished
Egyptian scholar;
Dr. Eldamaty received his Bachelors
and Masters of Arts degrees
from the faculty...Sorry...faculty
of Archaeology, Cairo University.
He received his Doctorate
of Philosophy in Egyptology
from Trier University, Germany.
At present, he's a professor
of Egyptology at faculty
of Ain Shams University in Egypt.
Dr. Eldamaty received many
international awards such as Legion
of Honor "Cavalier" from the
Italian Government in 2004.
Gold Medal at Charles
University in Prague in 2010.
The State Award for Excellence
in Social Sciences in 2010.
In his academic career, he's held
positions at University of Ain Shams
such as Chairman of the Department
of Archaeology faculty of arts,
Director of the Center for Research
Counseling and Training faculty
of arts, Director of Open Learning
Center for academic year 2009,
Dean Faculty of Arts from 2009-2011.
Dr. Eldamaty also held an
administrative position
such as Director General of
the Egyptian Museum in Cairo
and Supervisor of the
abroad exhibition
in the world from 2001-2004.
Culture Council and Director of
the Office of Educational Mission
and Egyptian Embassy in
Germany for 2011-2013.
At the same time, he was also
supervising the educational mission
in the Netherlands, Denmark,
Finland, Sweden, and Norway.
Minister of Antiquities
from 2014-2016.
Dr. Eldamaty is a member
in many international academic
associations of Egyptologists.
To date, Dr. Eldamaty has
published 36 books and articles.
Please join me to welcome
Dr. Eldamaty.
Please.
[applause]
>>MAMDOUH ELDAMATY:
Thank you very much.
Doctor Fawzi Tadros,
Mrs. Mary-Jane Deeb.
Dear colleagues, distinguished
guests, it is honor to me ...
Could I take it in
my hand like this?
Actually it is a great pleasure and
honor to me to be with you today
in the Library of the Congress, and
thanks to the Department of African
and Eastern and Near East ...
Middle East, sorry.
African and Middle East, and
thanks also to the Cultural Bureau
of the Egyptian Embassy for
inviting me for this event.
To talk about the Egyptian
antiquities,
especially the Great Pyramid
and the Tomb of Tutankhamun,
it means we have to
talk about secrets.
We couldn't maybe define
what we have there exact,
until we discover all the secrets
of these two important
monuments of Egypt.
But actually it takes a lot of time.
The Great Pyramid we can say it
is the wonder of the wonders,
the most important wonder of the
world who stay until nowadays.
The King Khufu, Cheops, is one
of the most important kings
who ruled Egypt about 23 years.
Started from 2600 BC,
4,600 years now.
Unfortunately we have for this king
only this statuette made of ivory,
nine centimeter high, but we don't
have other sculpture for him,
but we have the Great Pyramid.
The first it started
with the Great Pyramid
and to make some research
it was from Richard Pococke,
and he did this sketch of the
pyramids, 1754, and as you see
above the burial chamber,
actually nowadays,
by the new scholars we found five
chambers above the burial chamber.
You cannot see them here because
it's not discovered until that day,
but here we have these rooms
found by Howard Vyse, 1837.
And in the top one of them we
found the name of King Khufu,
the cartouche of King Khufu, Cheops.
From this day we know that this
pyramid belonged to the King Khufu.
Then later we have a most
important study of one
of the important scholar of
Egyptology, Flinders Petrie.
He's England, a English person,
but he did a lot of work in Egypt
in several places,
especially in Giza.
He wrote his book about
pyramids and temples of Giza.
And he did the first accurate
measurements of the pyramids,
which we use until nowadays.
When he was in Giza in
that time, as you see,
Sphinx was until that day covered
with sand, which removed now
and you can see also in front
of the pyramid big space, empty,
free space, not full of houses
like what we have nowadays.
The idea of the pyramid we can
talk about special architect
or a special wonder, which built
2600 BC, the high of the pyramid
in the time of King
Cheops, ancient 481 feet.
Nowadays it is we lost
some meters from the top
and the high nowadays is 455 feet.
The base of the pyramid: 756 feet.
The volume: 91,227,778 cubic feet.
Huge building.
The mass of the pyramid
is 5.9 million tons,
2.3 million blocks of sandstone.
This huge work takes
time, about 20 years
to build this pyramid, but how?
We still have the secret.
The famous architect of
the pyramid was Hamun.
He was a cousin of King Khufu.
Here the statue hosted now in the
Museum of Hildesheim in Germany,
and if you look to this plan,
you see that the pyramid take three
stages to build this Great Pyramid.
The first stage on the top here,
when we had the real burial chamber
of the king under the ground in the
mother rock of the plateau of Giza.
Then the architect changed his mind
to build another burial chamber
for the king on the top of
the ground in the building.
This chamber called now the Room
of the Queen or the Queen Chamber,
but actually did the second
chamber of King Khufu himself.
Then for the last time or the
third time he changed again
and built the burial chamber
of the king in the first third
of the high of the pyramid.
But how? Is the most
important question.
How, it is one of the secrets
of the pyramid: how it's built.
Some scholars thought about the
so-called causeways, it is ramp.
The ramp goes to the pyramid
and they build the first layer,
then extended their ramp until
we reach the top of the pyramid,
but it could be 1.6 kilometer long.
It is very difficult, or we have to
make up with a very dangerous angle,
also it is difficult to imagine.
Then we stay by ramp, but
surrounding the pyramid
from outside until the top.
It means it is 1.6
kilometer not in straight way,
but surrounding the pyramid
from top to the bottom.
And we can imagine it would work
like this to go around the pyramid
until reaching the
top of the pyramid.
But, come for us special question
and very difficult question,
because we know that the pyramid
after finishing will be covered
from outside making a casing of
the pyramid with white limestone.
The main stones of the pyramid
come from the main quarry of Giza,
from the same plateau used to build
this pyramid, but the covering,
the case, casing of the pyramid
come from white limestone from Tora,
about 15 kilometers out of Cairo.
Casing like this here,
we have this pyramid
of King Sneferu, the
father of Cheops.
This pyramid in Dahshur, and
until now we have the casing
of the pyramid, as you see, this
very fine casing from outside.
How we can do this by
the pyramid of Cheops
when we did the external ramp
round surrounding the pyramid?
It could be difficult.
Then some French scholar,
1986, went to the pyramid
and they have a new
method of technology.
It is microgravimetry.
This method used to measure the
vibration and the mass and density
of the pyramid from inside.
They spent about one month.
They make more than 1,000 mass for
this, and they said at the end,
"We have so-called sub-density,"
or zone of empty spaces
inside the pyramid,
which you can see here
by white and green.
It means we have swirl
inside the pyramid to show us
that we have maybe the
ramp inside the pyramid.
The measuring tell us that the
pyramid itself lost about 15%
from its mass from
inside, or from the density
of the pyramid from inside.
Then this work taken
by the architect Jean-Pierre
Houdin, he is French architect.
His father also is architect.
They discuss together
the results of 1986,
and they try to make
imagination how it could be built.
Then they thought that we have
two ramps, one from outside,
external ramp until about
third of the pyramid,
then we have another ramp, internal
ramp from inside the pyramid.
And they think it should
be like this.
Then we can build the
pyramid from the first layer
with its casing directly
together until the end.
But, after they finished, they can
then close the way from outside.
Here, as you see, how they put the
casing, and the casing from outside
from the beginning helps the
people to make sure from the angle
of the pyramid, and to protect
the measuring of the pyramid.
They have to make it from outside,
and then from inside
they put other blocks.
Then he met with a
Egyptologist, Bob Brier, American,
and they discussed
together what it should be,
and they make together this book:
The Secret of the Great Pyramid,
published 2009, published 2009.
Then we started now then to make
a new scan for the pyramids.
Two of the projects under this
provision and the cooperation
of the Ministry of Antiquities
with the Cairo University Faculty
of Engineering with HIP,
Heritage, Innovation,
and Preservation, an
institute from Paris.
Here we announced it
in October 2015.
I stay in the middle and the
colleagues to announce new project
of ScanPyramids to know
what we have exact.
In this, we work also with Laval
University in Quebec, Canada,
and Nagoya University of Japan.
The goal of our team is to probe
the heart of the largest pyramids
of Egypt without drilling
the slightest opening.
It means we have to
protect the building itself
until we're sure 100% we
have something inside.
Then we can do the drilling.
Before that, we cannot.
What we did, we have to use new
technology to help for this scan.
One of them is muon detection.
Muon is some cosmic rays.
We will talk about it.
And the second one
infrared thermography
and reconstruction with 3D scan.
These three methods we have to use
to solve this problem or to be sure
if we have something
inside, empty or not.
Actually, we're sure
we have something.
We have new secrets in the
pyramids, but we cannot be accurate.
Then we start with the
five great pyramids.
As you know we have more
than 40 pyramids in Egypt,
but the most important is the
pyramids of Giza and Dahshur,
these five pyramids, three
in Giza and two in Dahshur.
We start to make infrared
scan around the Great Pyramid
from all sides, and all the time of
the days: in the morning, in midday,
the evening, through the night.
This helps us to found thermal
anomaly in the north side
of the Great Pyramid, here,
by the first layer or first
and second layer of stones.
What it should be?
We found here because the
infrared thermography measured the
temperature of the surface
of the sides of the pyramids.
And here, we found, as you see
here, the red color, it means hot.
We have always six degree
difference between these two blocks
and the other side of the pyramid.
If we measure it in the morning,
in the midday, in the evening,
we have always six
degree difference.
It means we have here something
behind this red color stone,
but what should be?
We don't know.
But, if we look to the stones
here, it is totally different
by the design and construction
than the other of the other sides.
It's totally different.
That time when I announced
it in November 9, 2015,
we did press conference in the
pyramid and we announce about it,
and I said in that time that this
picture should be the famous picture
or most important picture
of year 2015.
It is the photo of Cheops,
here, we stand beside this area.
Again, to show here exact ...
Look to the blocks beside.
It is very different than this.
It means it was here
a door, empty space,
and covered with another
blocks later
after the finishing of the pyramid.
We continue this.
Two days later Zahi Hawass
went to the same area to share
with us what we have to do there.
Then we know that Zahi Hawass had
started also before to search,
to try to found also the
secret of the pyramid,
and he make drill inside
the pyramid,
but unfortunately he
didn't found anything.
That what led us to say we have
first to improve everything
to be sure before we drill again.
The thermal anomalies in
Khufu, Cheops, we found more.
We started with what I show you.
It was number one here,
what I show you.
But, we have another
places also to found.
One, two, five, and
six, it is similar.
Look at this here, it is by two.
They have the same
construction of blocks
like what we had in the first one.
It means here we have anomaly which
tell us we have something behind,
but unfortunately until nowadays we
cannot be sure exact what is behind,
and we cannot do a drill to show.
Then the second one,
it is muon radiography.
Muon is currently the only
technology that can see
through all genetic objects
and it is used by the Japanese
to solve the problems in ...
They come from the earth,
actually, and millions of them
through the atmosphere of
the earth, from our bodies,
through our- we have about
between two to three million
of these muons passing through
our body, but it is safe.
Nothing happened with our
body, no side effects.
The Japanese, as I told you,
they use it to know the secret
of volcano: when the
volcano could be active.
They found what is
inside like this here.
Then they try to use this
technology to make also a picture
of the pyramid from inside.
We will use this technique for
the whole Great Pyramids, the two,
one from Dahshur, first
one, Bent Pyramid.
That's the north one of
Dahshur, the Great Pyramid
of Khufu, the Pyramid of Khafre.
We have to start with this one,
because we know exact what is
behind, what's inside the pyramid,
and we would like to be sure
that this method is accurate
to find what we have inside.
Then we using it.
Now, here you see the
professional man.
He is a genius person to 25
years old from Japan, Yoshimura.
Doctor Yoshimura.
I'm sorry, his name is difficult.
Yeah. He put here the plates inside
the down chamber of the Bent Pyramid
to collect the radius, and
after that they will take them
to develop these plates in
the Grand Egyptian Museum.
We have a special lab in
the Grand Egyptian Museum
to make the development
of these plates.
Then taken to Japan to
continue the analysis.
It takes inside the pyramid 80
days, and some days for development,
and another two months
in Japan for analysis.
They did it first a computer
simulation what we have to seen
after the analyses of these plates,
and it should be the
photo like this.
After that, sure, we compare between
what we have inside the simulation
of the computer and the result
what we read from muons.
It is accurate and it is the same.
Then it is new methods we have
to trust and we have to continue
with this method in
the Pyramid of Giza.
Then we put them in two places
inside the Great Pyramid of Khufu,
one inside the second
chamber in the middle,
and we have to measure this area.
The second one, on the
gallery directly some meters
after the main entrance
of the pyramid,
and to use and cover this area.
We started already, and now the
plate's in Japan for the analysis.
We wait for the result and we hope
that we have a good result there.
The third method is the 3D scan to
make from outside accurate figures,
accurate pictures, 3D pictures like
this here by the main entrance.
That by the Great Pyramid and
we have to wait for the results.
Until now, we can say we
have to found something.
We are sure to found something,
but exact where inside the pyramid,
how it should be, this gallery,
this room, chamber, another chamber
with some furniture of
the king, we don't know.
Then we have to wait, but also we
have to follow the new technology
and trust the technology.
The second part is Tomb of
Tutankhamun radar survey.
Actually, we had 1,000 of
visitors to visit the tomb of King
of Tutankhamun before 2011, and
to save the tombs from a lot
of visitors we had the project
to make facsimile for the tomb,
exact one-to-one, to help
for us when we close the Tomb
of Tutankhamun for
restoration or conservation,
then the visitors they can
visit the other facsimile
or copy of this tomb.
It started by the work of Basel
University with Factum Arte
and the Factum Foundation,
and finished 2009.
They did a high resolution pictures,
laser pictures, which very important
for us to continue our search.
As you see here it is the
new facsimile, and the person
who visit already the
tomb of King Tutankhamun,
he cannot found any difference.
It is typical one-to-one.
Then we took this high resolution
picture for another new search.
Nicholas Reeves is one of
the scholar Egyptologists.
He worked a lot in the
Valley of the Kings.
We can say the man of the Valley
of the Kings is Nicholas Reeves,
and he did a search
with these pictures,
and after that he wrote
an article and he think
that we have the burial chamber
of Nefertiti behind the burial
chamber of King Tutankhamun.
He published his article
in July 2015.
Directly after that, it got a lot
of attack from many scholars: "No.
It is dream of him.
He is crazy.
How it could be?"
And something like this.
The media called me and they
would like to know my opinion
about the article about
what Reeves said,
but until that time I didn't
read the article of him.
I told them, "Stop.
Reeves is a good scholar.
He know what he does in the Valley
of the Kings, and it is his work,
and I have to read first the
article to know what he wrote,
and then I can say my opinion."
I read the article, and I found a
lot of important things inside this,
many points we have to
discuss and to be sure
of they are accurate or not.
Then I called him by phone in
London, and when I told him,
"I am Mamdouh Eldamaty, the
Minister of Antiquities,"
I said, he lost first the words.
Then: "You are Eldamaty the
Egyptian Minister of Antiquities?"
"Yes. I am."
He was very happy that
we take it in mind.
I asked him to come to Egypt to
discuss together about his points
in the Tomb of Tutankhamun
in the Valley of the Kings.
He accepted and in one week he
came to Egypt and we went together.
He show us the article here-
the black and white down.
It is the laser photo
from Factum Arte.
And he compared it and he found
here these remains four, five,
six should be here in this area.
He think it should be a door and
it's closed later by the finishing
of the Tomb of Tutankhamun.
Reeves think also that this tomb
belong first to the Queen Nefertiti,
because normally when
we have tombs of queens,
we found after the main
entrance and the gallery,
we have here a special hall,
then the architect goes
to the right side, it is queen,
but when it goes to the left side
and it continued in the
left side, it is king.
Then you think it is a queen,
and at the beginning it should
be only the main gallery,
this gallery here, and went with
this door to another burial chamber.
But, suddenly thought of suddenly
death of King Tutankhamen.
He died suddenly when he
was 19-years-old and in
that time we didn't
have tomb for him.
Then the Egyptian they have to
build for him a tomb to bury him.
And they cut special part from the
tomb, from the oldest tomb, maybe,
as Reeves said, of Nefertiti or
of another person, and he used it
as the burial chamber and
tomb of King Tutankhamen.
But, he has to make it as a tomb,
because they cut only place then.
He make extension in the left side
after the entrance with magazine
and also another room in the east
side, and make the ground deep,
about 60 centimeter deep, and
extension to the west side,
to the left, this west side.
Then continued the surfaces
of the burial chamber.
Only this chamber is painted.
The other chamber is not.
Here he found also the
remains of the wall,
which is cut to make the
extension to that west side.
We went to the tomb together.
Here Reeves in the middle, it's
me, here Doctor Khaled El-Anany,
the new Minister of Antiquities
now, Mahmoud Afify, Sultan Muhammed,
Mustafa Waziri, group
of people went together
to discuss the details
and what he did.
There I found a new point to
add to the theory of Reeves.
It is we have here different
between the finishing of the surface
in the bottom part of the north
wall, east side, and the top
and the rest of the wall.
Here is clear.
You can see it is here
another plaster added,
and the remain of brush.
Then take a paint, a special
plaster and paint it later.
On the top here, directly
you can see the different.
Here it is the rock, the
main rock, the mother rock
of the tomb painted also
with yellow like this,
but you can see the
different of the surfaces.
We had something like this
before by the beginning
and the discovery of
the tomb 2019 ...
1922 by Howard Carter.
The burial chamber was closed
with the same plaster, this here.
And you can see also the
remains of the brush.
It means he used this and covered
with yellow color,
then painted the wall.
Then we did press conference,
but Reeves decided
to say it is a tomb of Nefertiti.
Actually, I agree with him,
we found something here,
but I disagree it is Nefertiti.
Why? Reeves is saying that Nefertiti
ruled Egypt directly after the death
of King Akhenaton, and she is
back from Tell el-Amarna to Luxor.
She changed her name to be
Smenkhkare, to be a king,
to be a queen to Egypt, and she did
for herself a burial chamber there
in the Tomb of Tutankhamun, behind
the tomb of King Tutankhamun,
and she brought with her the
mummy of her husband Akhenaton,
and she did for him a burial
in the Valley of the Kings,
the so-called KV, Kings Valley, 55.
But, my opinion said, yeah,
Doctor Zahi Hawass also tried
to found king, Queen Nefertiti
and he wrote this article in Horas
in January 2007, to search Nefertiti
in the Valley of the Kings,
after the theory of
Reeves in that time also.
It means Reeves thought
that Nefertiti is there
since a long time.
The City of Tell el-Amarna, which
built by Akhenaton and Nefertiti
in Minya mid-Egypt
surrounded by Boundary stele,
and here these red points.
They have two of these
Boundary stele.
On this Boundary stele, King
Akhenaton and Nefertiti swear
with the name of the God Atum they
will never leave Tell el-Amarna,
living there, die there,
and buried there.
And also, we found the real
tomb of Tell el-Amarna,
of Akhenaton and Nefertiti there.
Yeah. We found his tomb empty,
right, but this tomb built for them.
It means, in my opinion she
must be there or buried there.
We didn't found her
body, but it is its tomb.
It's her tomb, not in
Valley of the Kings.
Here the tomb KV55,
we found in KV55,
remains of bones and skull of king.
We think it is a king
called Smenkhkare,
the younger brother
of King Akhenaton.
Reeves has said, no, it is
Akhenaton himself, and Smenkhkare,
it is another name of Nefertiti,
and she is not buried there
in this tomb, but behind the
burial chamber of King Tutankhamun.
It is the two opinion: Akhenaton,
Smenkhkare; Smenkhkare, Nefertiti.
And inside this tomb KV55, we found
here this canopic jar of Meritaten,
this daughter of Nefertiti and
sister of King Tutankhamun.
We have some remains
belonging to Kiya.
Kiya is the mother
of King Tutankhamun.
We have also some pieces
to Queen Tiye,
the grandmother of King Tutankhamun.
Then, we have things to tell
us that Kiya, Meritatun,
and Tiye must be buried in
the Valley of the Kings,
but we didn't have the tombs of
them, but we didn't have any remains
of Nefertiti inside this tomb.
For this reason I think
when we found a burial
chamber behind the tomb
of Tutankhamen could be for
another lady, not for Nefertiti.
Actually until now
we couldn't be sure
that is a burial chamber behind.
What we did after that, we
started to make radar scan.
We brought radar scan, radar from
Japan to 26-27 of November 2015,
and first we did the radar in KV5.
KV5 it is the tomb of the
sons of King Ramesses II,
because we know exact
the rooms inside.
Then when we do radar, then the
result should tell us what we have
there to be sure, as a test
radar to make it first.
Then also when we went to the Tomb
of Tutankhamun, we started also
with the main side of the
antechamber of the King Tutankhamun,
because we know in this side,
to the east side behind it
also should be empty space
of the magazine of this annex,
and solid space of the rock,
the mother rock of the mountain
of the Valley of the Kings.
Then, when we have the result here
is accurate with what we have,
it means we have to trust the system
and we have to continue with it.
Here Watanabe, Mister Watanabe
by working to make the radar scan
on the north wall of
the antechamber.
And it is a result, as you see,
you can see here the line
divided the two sides.
Here's empty behind,
and here's solid behind.
That tell us, yes, we can
follow and trust this system.
We continue in other sides
of the burial chamber,
here at the north side, by
discussion about the results,
Watanabe, Reeves, his
assistant and me.
Then, we found some very
important things like this picture
of the radar for the north
wall of the burial chamber.
I think it is clear to see
that here by this stick
and down it is a different
between the two sides.
It is very clear.
Here we have a solid side
behind, and here it's empty space,
and with this curve Mister
Watanabe said it could be a curve
of a door lintel.
Yeah. Like this.
But, also, the end he said,
"We can see that we have
something behind the north wall
and the west wall of
the burial chamber."
He thought maybe it is another
chamber, and give also this picture.
And he said, "Could be we have
something solid or metal inside,
and something soft
inside these two rooms."
That means we have some furniture,
but it is also difficult to say.
For this reason we would like
to make another radar scan.
We thought about three
types of radar scan to do,
and also one infrared thermography.
The second one we did,
the infrared thermography.
But, unfortunately we do it in
small place on the north wall,
only in the space where we thought
that we have here a door lintel,
to know exact if we have
here something or not.
But, actually, we have to
repeat it for the whole side
of the north side of
the burial chamber.
Here the result is similar to
what we had before by Factum Arte.
Maybe here a little bit
clearer than before,
but we have to repeat this again.
We did another radar with the
help of National Geographic,
but after that we sent this radar
to two types of analyzed scan data
by GPR and here by RADAN.
They are two types of analyze
system, and the results
by GPR come by Goodman and Dash.
Goodman said we didn't have
anything behind the north wall.
It means we have nothing behind.
But, Dash said, "No, we cannot read
or do any analyze for this data,
because we have a lot of noise,
and noisy is difficult to read."
Then we have to repeat this again.
Also, by RADAN the two person,
Waters said the same, like Dash.
We have to repeat it again
because we have noisy.
But, Abassid, we don't
have anything.
It means two persons said
we don't have anything.
The other two persons said we have
to repeat it because we have noisy.
It is not accurate
read, accurate data.
Then it means we have to repeat
it again, because Watanabe, Japan,
said we have something here.
Here, we have nothing,
or we have to repeat.
The work is continued now,
and at the end of this month,
or in April now, next month, we have
to repeat the radar scan this time
from the top of the tomb.
Then we have to do it
another time from inside
with infrared scan from inside.
Then we can say what we have.
Thank you very much.
[applause]
>>FAWZI TADROS: Dr. Robert, please.
>>AUDIENCE MEMBER: (inaudible)
>>ALDAMATY: Actually, JAM is one
of the modern museum in the world.
We have very high standard lab
there and we built special section
to develop the rajas there
but not to analyze them
because to analyze it needs more
technique, more money, more place
and the technique we have in Japan
we develop it in JAM and send it
to Japan to continue the work.
>>AUDIENCE MEMBER: (inaudible)
>>ALDAMATY: Actually, I hope
Reeves is right and I'm wrong.
To find Nefertiti- it
is more fascinating.
The relationship.
Akhenaton, the father of Tutankhamun
and Nefertiti's step
mother and yeah.
>>AUDIENCE MEMBER: (inaudible)
>>ALDAMATY: Kaya, yeah,
but also not 100%
because you didn't have any
documents which tell us exact
that Tutankhamun is the
son of Kaya and Akhenaton.
We know exact that Akhenaton and
Nefertiti had 6 daughters, not boy.
But, we have a boy that is
the son of Akhenaton then
from the other lady and we know that
Akhenaton married also with Kaya.
Probably she was the
mother of him...
Please.
>>AUDIENCE MEMBER: (inaudible)
>>ALDAMATY: Actually, as
you said, Akhenaton lived
in Egypt he left Luxor
and went to Tell Aman,
built his new city surrounded
by his (inaudible) would
like to be a new place
without other cuts except Atun.
Tutankhamun, he was
born in Tell Aman.
His name actually was Tutank Atun,
the living image of the God, Atun.
2 years later he came to
Luxor and he changed his name
to be Tutankhamun and he made
the decree to continue the work,
but started already before Akhenaton
and he worshipped the
God Amun again.
But, in the same time we have
some opinion from some scholar
that before him, maybe Nefertiti
came to Luxor or King Samakare.
For this reason, we have
the tomb KV55 there.
To find the tomb or the burial
chamber behind the burial chamber
of Tutankhamun as I said is not till
now true because it could be old
so that when the architect
built the tomb of Tutankhamun,
he tried to continue with
another chamber in the north side.
But, he stopped directly after
the death of King Tutankhamun
and he covered this maybe short
cave or some we don't know.
If it is only this or special
room burial chamber empty space,
we don't know.
We have to be sure.
[applause]
>>FAWZI TADROS: (inaudible)
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc dot gov.